and so you're telling me I failed
because I didn't have the resources and
I'm here to tell you what you already
know resources are never the problem
it's a lack of resourcefulness is why
you failed six people share $7 a mouth
we can only eat the one chicken a year
what's terrible some people see the
thing that they want and some people see
the thing that prevents them from
getting the thing that they want
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna look at
the seven things really resourceful
people do enjoy all right kicking us off
with rule number one is they burn their
ships with Tony Robbins everything you
people have told me I didn't have the
technology I'd have the right contacts I
didn't have the time I didn't have money
everything you've told me I didn't have
enough Supreme Court justices those are
resources and so you're telling me I
fail because I didn't have the resources
and I'm here to tell you what you
already know resources are never the
problem it's a lack of resourcefulness
is why you failed because the ultimate
resources are emotional states if you're
creative enough can you find the answer
yes or no if you're determined enough
can you find the breakthrough yes or no
if you're passionate loving enough can
you get someone to help you yes or no if
there's no way that you're committed can
you find the money even if you don't
have it yes or no
so I said creativity decisiveness
passion honesty sincerity love these are
the ultimate human resources and when
you engage these resource you can get
any other resource on earth and I said
so you told me all the resources you're
missing and you hypnotize yourself into
believing that you don't have what you
want because you don't the resources
when the most successful people in
history have no resources but they were
incredibly resourceful so they got the
resources resourcefulness is the
ultimate resource and if you don't have
what you want stop telling yourself the
story because you don't the money all
the time
that's [ __ ] it's because you haven't
committed yourself where you would burn
your boats if you want to take the fun
Island burn your
votes and you will take the island
because people when they're gonna either
die or succeed tend to succeed but most
of us give ourselves a way out and
that's why we don't have what we want
rule number two is that they seize every
opportunity of Jack Ma I was born a very
normal family and poor family six people
sure $7 mouth we can only eat the one
chicken a year what's terrible Nixon
visit to my city 1972 China USA signed a
Mao Zedong Nixon Sunday Agreement so
China become opened oh my City Council
was one of the first cities that opened
to the west we got a lot of American
tourists to visit my city what he would
do is he would befriend foreign visitors
who came to Hangzhou to walk around the
west lake there and I learned English by
being the free guide tour guide you know
more than the language Jack was learning
about the culture the things I learned
from books from China are so different
from the things I learned from the
American visitors so I start to think
differently rule number three is they
bend the rules with simon Sinek
let me tell you a story so a friend of
mine and I we went for a run in Central
Park the Roadrunners organization on the
weekends they host races and it's very
common at the end of the race they'll
have a sponsor who will give away
something apples or bagels or something
and on this particular day when we got
to the end of the run there were some
free bagels and they had picnic tables
set up and on one side was a group of
volunteers on the table were boxes of
bagels and on the other side was a long
line of runners waiting to get their
free bagel so I said to my friend let's
let's get a bagel and he looked at me
and said that lines too long and I said
free bagel and he said I don't want to
wait in line and I was like free bagel
and he says not let's it's too long and
that's when I realized that there's two
ways to see the world some people see
the thing that they want and some people
see the thing that prevents them from
getting the thing that they want I could
only see the bagels he could only see
the line and so I walked up to the line
I leaned in between two people put my
hand in the box and pulled out two
bagels and no one get mad at me because
the rule is you can go after whatever
you want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want
now I had to sacrifice choice I didn't
get to choose which bagel I got I got
whatever I pulled out but I didn't have
to wait in line so the point is is you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it you can do it your way you can
break the rules you just can't get in
the way of somebody else getting what
they want that's rule number one
rule number four is they adapt and
improvise with Julius llego by then no
and Kenan can have a place for EE in
training they didn't have any court
I was doing training alone I saw it as
like life was going against me to us the
lowest fool
[Music]
but I didn't even keep up something came
into my mind
- what the YouTube videos I could go to
the cyber look at the great javelin
throwers see what they do in the normal
training and I will come and practice
the following day
we do not have the facilities you try on
yourself to improvise what you have
the past few years when I was doing the
training alone was a big challenge but
now I have partners we train together
Metro training easy and though it's it's
fun I like being me
the videos of these guys really helped
me a lot in 2010 I throw 75 after that I
keep watching this video
[Music]
in 2011 I want the O'Laughlin games it
was the first time that Kenya was
winning a gold medal in jelly
in 2012 when I threw it 181 nice cream
because I couldn't believe that I was
making the Olympic finals for the first
time somebody in the finals from Kenya
and Africa as well I didn't stop from
there in 2014 it was a big thing by one
goal for the first time in football
games 2015 is especially affirming the
world championships 92 meters no a big
draw and winning a gold medal I will
never forget that forever
now I'm the world champion it's like a
dream rule number five is they grow
their social network with Mark
Zuckerberg but the students around me
were really important as well right and
both in high school and in college I
mean the people who started Facebook
with me and a lot of people who are
still with me running the company today
are people who I met when I was at
Harvard and some of them were mighty ups
at Harvard right and you know when the
professors were off writing papers these
were the people who actually taught me
and then we hung out and we had like
social bonds and academic bonds and I
just I wouldn't understate the
importance of that and I mean it's very
tied into my whole philosophy and the
product that that I spend my life
building Facebook because we just
believe that social bonds are critical
and um in one way that I think about the
the value that Facebook is filling in
the world is that you go through school
and at least when I did people just
focused on you know academics like
achievement different areas and one of
the things that no one really ever
taught me was like having friends is
really valuable no I did not that I
didn't have friends but but like
although you know the movie yes make it
seem that
but that first girlfriend is for sure I
don't think anyone is like it's not like
okay third grade we're gonna like
now we're gonna like teach you that like
hanging out with people is a very
important development right and I don't
know I actually think that that is and I
think that's part of the reason why
sometimes people view Facebook as a
waste of time but I actually think it's
this extremely socially valuable utility
and I know that I wouldn't be where I
want where I am today without that
aspect of my life being as developed as
the academic part rule number six is
they are proactive with icecube
and I'm doing my career my way you know
being able to put together your own
movies is a blessing you know most
actors are just sitting around waiting
for somebody to say hey you wanna be in
my movie so I don't like that I would I
wouldn't be active if I was just sitting
around so I love producing I love
writing and just making sure it happened
now you got to be proactive and rule
number seven they are persistent with
Kamiya Cabello I went to the producer
round of The X Factor and after that
they send you to perform for the actual
judges and so when they wrote me the
letter basically they said that I was a
with what's that called alternate write
and alternate and alternate which means
that you're not guaranteed a spot to
audition in front of the judges
and if they have time at the end of the
show then you can audition but that's
never again you'll sit there and wait
wait wait so the auditions were all the
way in North Carolina and so my whole
family and I traveled to North Carolina
to see if maybe I could audition so the
auditions the judges auditions are three
days the first day I get there and I'm
to go on the stage and sing and I have
my microphone in my hand and a producer
comes and says sorry we don't have
enough time I do keep going throughout
the days your name keeps going down and
down on a list because there's different
alternates for every day so anyway so
that so then I said okay like I'm just
gonna try like to come the next day so
the next thing I come same like same
basically the same thing happened and
I'm a crying like backstage and the
producer like my grandma's there that my
grandma's crying cuz we were all like
this sucks like I'm not gonna get a
chance to audition and I wanted it so
badly and they were like honestly you
shouldn't come at all anymore because I
don't want to see your family
disappointed if you come tomorrow
there's not gonna be any room for you to
audition I honestly think you should
just go home and try again next year
yeah and so Simon Cowell luckily walks
out like behind the stage and I was like
you were a really tight white shirt yeah
and I was like I was like Simon they
won't let me audition could you please
let me audition Simon and all the judges
on the show they have no idea what the
alternate process is actually like they
just see people walk out on stage
give them a s whatever and so he was
like oh yeah for sure you can audition
and I turn over to the executive
producer and I was like don't like see
he's Simon Cowell and he's telling me I
can't addition can't move I like yeah
thanks and like can I please just come
back tomorrow and so basically to sum up
the story they saw how persistent I was
and how much I wanted to be there
because I ended up like just crying that
producer I'm being like honestly I don't
even have to you don't even have to put
me as an alternate amaro I just want to
be in the building to know that I did
that I did everything that I could to
know that if there maybe is a 1% chance
that I'm allowed to audition that I'm
here that I'm still here for it and so
they saw how persistent I was and the
next
ended up letting me audition
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Richard Branson on being bold but
before that my question of the day is
what is the most resourceful thing that
you will have ever done in your life for
your business leave it down the comments
below I'm really curious to see what you
have to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
I was flying from the British Virgin
Islands no sorry from Puerto Rico to the
British Virgin Islands and and I was 28
years old and I been away from home for
three weeks and I had this gorgeous lady
waiting for me and and American Airlines
announced that they are banned that then
they're not going to fly the flight till
the next morning they hadn't didn't have
enough passengers and I was damned if I
was going to wait till the next morning
and so I went to the back of the airport
and I borrowed a black board and I
scribbled Virgin Airlines as a joke $39
one-way to the British Virgin Islands
and went around all the passengers and I
managed to fill up my first flight and
and when I got to the BVI
the guy on my left you know turned to me
and said you sharpen up the surface a
bit and you could be in the airline
business and and the next day anyway the
night went well then the next day I rang
up Boeing and I said I'm thinking of
going to the airline business so in fact
I've just had my test flight they do you
have any secondhand 747s for sale and
the person who took the phone call I
thought he was going to put the phone
down on me but he you know he hung on in
there
so he said well you know what what does
your company do and I said well you know
we're a record company we've got the
Rolling Stones we got the Sex Pistols
we've and again he didn't sound very
very you know they say what's the name
of the company and I said virgin and
there was a long pause and he said well
it will send a salesman to see you but
with a name like virgin and I just hope
your airline goes the whole way
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that means that people
have passion and not one drop of myself
work depends on your it's suppose to
mean I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten most of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
Clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details